now that
is an incredibly important thing
to see your background your experience
your history represented out there in
the world having a voice speaking on a
platform doing the things that perhaps
you hope that you would be able to do if
you can't see yourself out there or
anyone who looks like you or sounds like
you
it's very hard to imagine that you'll be
able to do that as well and that's one
part
of what was incredibly important I've
realized over the years of what was
incredibly important about me being able
to have the life and the opportunities
in the career that I've had
there's only one part
I've realized more and more as time has
gone on
how much I owe
everything all the opportunities I've
had to other people and the work of
other people